and one day steve martin is just in  front of his house so i jumped out of  the car and i asked him for his  autograph he said i can't because then  people are going to come all the time  i went home in a rage i was like i  wanted i was so mad  you're someone who uses improvisation  with great control i think other people  see what you're doing and think oh right  improv that's how you do it most days  it's really not improv it's  rewriting on its feet  somewhere in my head i must have thought  oh you can do that in comedy if you're  just a lunatic and you work hard and you  obsess over it you can get in so i  always thought i could get in i just  knew it would take a crazy amount of  work  i need a fun writer's room i just do i  need it to be a show i need the writer's  room to be a show and i've been kicked  out by my writers because i'm wasting  their time